bon inception alors sciences ou réalité
est ce qu'on peut vous implanter un
souvenir malgré vous pendant que vous
dormez pendant que vous rêvez si on veut
manipuler vos rêves
il faut comprendre les rêves et pour
comprendre les rêves
il faut comprendre la mémoire parce que
tous vos rêves sont construits à partir
d'expériences que vous avez vécu ou
imaginez si on veut comprendre la
mémoire je vous demander de faire un
voyage dans le temps
exactement en 1957 c'est l'année où
henri moléson a subi une opération pour
le soigner de crise d'épilepsie
à l'époque la seule possibilité pour le
soigner a été de lui enlever la partie
du cerveau responsables de ces crises
cette partie pour l'appel l'hippocampe
cette opération a réussi puisque il n'a
plus jamais fait crise d'épilepsie
le seul problème c'est que henry moléson
est devenu complètement amnésique il n'a
plus jamais formé de souvenirs de sa vie
que nous après cette expérience
dramatique à la première c'est que même
pour une opération importante
il ne faut surtout pas enlever cette
partie du cerveau
la deuxième c'est que cette toute petite
structure de votre cerveau votre
hippocampes et responsable de votre
mémoire
pas de votre intelligence pas de votre
raisonnement sont cuites et parfaitement
préservée l'ange juste de votre mémoire
mais si on veut comprendre la mémoire
bah ça suffit pas de savoir où ça se
passe parce que le cerveau c'est quoi le
cerveau c'est un ensemble de millions et
de dizaines de millions de neurones qui
communiquent entre eux et communiquent
entre eux par des petites impulsions
électriques
un peu comme si vous étiez les neurones
du cerveau la seule chose que vous
pouviez faire c'était tapé sur les
épaules de vos voisins
alors parfois avec un bras télescopique
mais c'est tout ce que vous pouvez faire
et pourtant cette communication très
simple élémentaire est responsable de
vos pensées de vos souvenirs et de vos
rêves
comment c'est possible pour essayer de
comprendre ça il faut pouvoir
enregistrer l'activité des neurones donc
on peut implanter une électrode à un
endroit et regardait l'activité d'une
centaine d'euros
bon bien sûr c'est très invasif faut
faire un trou dans le cerveau donc on
peut pas vraiment le faire chez l'homme
sauf cas très particuliers pour
simplifier le problème on étudie chez la
souris et on étudie plus
particulièrement la mémoire spatiale
donc la mémoire où se trouve le théâtre
du châtelet à paris
comment vous est venu ici où je me
trouve sur cette estrade on place les
souris dans des petits labyrinthes ou la
souris peut se déplacer aller à droite
allez à gauche pour retrouver un petit
morceau de fromage et en même temps on
va enregistrer l'activité des neurones
pour regarder comment il fonctionne et
ce qui a été observé
c'est que les neurones agissent comme
des cellules de lieux il ya des neurones
qui décharge quand je suis ici dans
l'environnement et chez la souris
il va y avoir un neurone par exemple
neurones entouré en rouge qui va
décharger quand la souris et
dans le bras de départ du labyrinthe
uniquement là si j'enregistre un autre
neurones à côté si je regarde son
activité le neurone va être actif quand
la souris et dans le bras en bas et en
fait l'activité des neurones c'est une
activité électrique
donc on peut la brancher sur un haut
parleur est en fait lorsque le neurone
verts par exemple est actif quand la
souris et dans la région verte
ben vous entendez ça et donc si vous
fermez les yeux et que vous entendez ce
bruit vous savez exactement où se trouve
la souris dans l'environnement
et si on enregistre une cinquantaine de
neurones qui couvre tout l'environnement
et qu'on utilise des algorithmes
mathématiques on appelle de machine
learning
on est capable de recalculer la position
de la souris dans un environnent dans ce
petit film
ce que vous voyez c'est le labyrinthe la
croix rouge représente la position
réelle de l'animal et les points bleus
et verts représente la position qu'on a
recalculé avec l'ordinateur
vous voyez très précisément la
trajectoire de la souris vous savez
uniquement en regardant l'écran
d'ordinateur où se trouve la source par
moments vous voyez des choses un petit
peu plus complexe comme si la souris
étaient à plusieurs endroits en même
temps en fait on ne pense pas que ce
soit le cas on pense qu'on est capable
de recalculer la position de la souris
mais également la trajectoire à laquelle
elle pense la trajectoire qu'elle est en
train de prédire
est ce que c'est le cas et bien
effectivement la souris a bien repris la
trajectoire qu'on avait prédit en
recalculant sa position donc on est
capable de lire les pensées de la souris
au moins de savoir où la souris dans ce
trou est ce qu'on peut les manipuler
maintenant c'est la khl sommeil entre en
jeu si on place la souris par exemple
sur cet environnement et qu'on lui donne
une récompense ici
si on a fait dormir plus tard dans sa
petite boîte
on va voir pendant son sommeil cette
cellule de lieux active et puis cette
cellule de lieux puis celle ci puisse
aussi comme s'il est en train de rêver
la trajectoire qu'elle a fait pendant
l'éveil et en fait c'est réactivation on
pense que c'est très important pour la
consolidation de la mémoire pour rejouer
les informations pendant le sommeil pour
les consolider
donc oui il faut apprendre ses leçons
voire en deçà rouge mais est ce que
c'est le cas à ce que c'est vrai parce
que pour être sûr il faudrait pouvoir
réveiller la souris quand vous voyez la
trajectoire et lui demander est-ce que
tu étais en train de rêver sera le seul
petit problème c'est que les souris ça
ne parle pas donc en fait on a fait un
imaginer une expérience que se
passerait-il si pendant que la souris
d'or lorsque cette cellule de lieux est
actif que se passerait-il si on lui
donnait une récompense à ce moment là
pendant qu'elle dort est ce qu'au réveil
la souris irait chercher la récompense
c'est exactement l'expérience qu'on a
réalisé à le s p c'est y pas très loin
d'ici avec mes étudiants qui sont ici
marie lacroix et gaëtan de la ville et
au bras ce moment vous êtes en train de
vous dire il est gentil mais il nous
vend un peu du rêve
parce que comment on fait pour donner
une récompense et une souris qui est en
train de dormir
et bien en fait c'est possible parce que
je vous ai dit que l'activité du cerveau
c'est une activité électrique et quand
on donne un grand morceau de fromage à
une souris on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une
petite région du cerveau qui est
fortement active et donc si on implante
une électrode de stimulation juste à cet
endroit on est capable de donner une
récompense à une souris donc on a
enregistré l'activité des neurones
pendant que la souris se déplacer et on
appris par exemple
cette cellule de lieu pendant le sommeil
on a dix années une interfaces cerveau
machine qui à chaque fois que la cellule
de lieux des charges et donc à chaque
fois que la souris pour simplifier
vais être à saint trond la ce a
déclenché automatiquement une
stimulation de récompenses puis on a
réveillé la souris on l'a remis dans
l'environnement et la souris est allé
directement dans l'endroit qu'on avait
récompensé pendant son sommeil cette
expérience nous montre qu' on a fait une
association entre une récompense et
l'activité des neurones est ce qu'on a
créé au réveil c'est l'association entre
un lieu de l'espace physique et une
récompense et donc ça montre un fort
lien entre l'activité du neurone quand
le neurone est actif je suis sûr que la
souris et à l'endroit où pense à
l'endroit ça nous a également montré
qu'on était capable de prendre un
souvenir et de le rendre en sommeil un
tout petit peu plus positif ou
potentiellement un tout petit peu plus
négatifs et chez l'homme alors comme je
voulais dit l'enregistrement de neurones
c'est très puissant mais c'est très
invasif faut faire un trou dans le
cerveau il ya des risques d'infection
est par contre chez l'homme on à l'irm
fonctionnelle
l'irm fonctionnelle c'est une énorme
machine qui permet de regarder
l'activité du cerveau sans avoir ouvrir
la boîte crânienne et une expérience
extrêmement passionnante qui a été
réalisé à berkeley les chercheurs
américains ont présenté un grand nombre
de films youtube pendant quatre ou cinq
heures et pendant que les sujets
regarder ses films il y avait un petit
programme informatique qui essayait de
faire le lien entre eux le film qui
était présenté à l'écran et l'activité
du cerveau dans l'irm
puis ils ont montré un film que les
patients les sujets n'ont jamais vu ce
film c'est ce que vous voyez sur la
droite de l'écran et sur la gauche
ça correspond à l'image qu'on a
recalculé à partir de l'activité du
cerveau on arrive à recalculer
exactement grande partie ce que les
sujets sont en train de voir donc avec
l'irm on est capable
de voir ce que pensent les sujets alors
avec l'expérience des souris
l'expérience chez l'homme
inception est ce que c'est possible
théoriquement oui on peut pas faire tout
et n'importe quoi
je suis désolé je vais pas pouvoir vous
faire apprendre l'anglais pendant que
vous dormez mais par contre on peut
prendre un souvenir et le rendre un peu
plus positif ou un peu plus négatifs
mais pour le manipuler on est obligé de
vous lui montrez pendant l'éveil
d'accord on peut pas le faire malgré
vous et on est obligé de vous le montrer
pendant quatre ou cinq heures et quand
le programme informatique a réussi à
décoder ces visions ça ne marche que
pour vous ça ne marche pas pour une
autre personne
donc on est très très loin de la
manipulation de masse donc si vous avez
peur de vous faire manipuler pendant
sommeil ou manipulé tout court à votre
insu vous conseille plutôt de faire
attention à la publicité
si on n'a pas en avoir peur est ce qu'on
peut s'en réjouir
eh bien oui parce que avec ces nouvelles
technologies on est capable de regarder
l'activité des neurones en lien avec la
pensée des souris et ça c'est un énorme
espoir pour les maladies
neuropsychiatriques qui touche justement
la pensée est l'autre grand intérêt
c'est que comme je voulais dit on est
capable de prendre un souvenir et de
rendre un peu plus positif et on espère
pouvoir utiliser ça dans le
développement de nouvelles thérapies
pour le stress post traumatique le
stress post traumatique c'est quoi le
stress post traumatique c'est des
patients des sujets qui ont fait une
association pathologique entre une
expérience et une réaction de peur
exacerbée
la seule thérapie à l'heure actuelle
c'est de demander aux patients de se
remettre dans la situation et en les
mettant dans un cadre un peu plus
confortable agréable d'essayer de casser
cette association pathologique
le seul problème c'est que même si on
utilise de l'imagerie virtuelle pour
rendre la situation plus immersive et
plus réel vous savez que c'est pas vrai
et plus important votre cerveau c'est
que ça n'est pas vrai l' avantage c'est
que pendant le rêve tout fait vrai dire
que quand je rêve je suis vraiment
batman c'est uniquement quand je me
réveille que je m'aperçois que et donc
si on arrive à identifier
pendant le sommeil les moments où les
sujets réactive ces expériences
traumatisantes
ce serait le moment idéal pour essayer
de casser
l'association pathologique toutes ces
applications potentielles et bien
d'autres simplement parce qu'on a réussi
à créer un ce faux souvenirs à une
petite souris à le spc juste à côté
et parce qu'on a réussi à le faire
pendant le sommeil et comme je voulais
dit il n'y a pas de quoi en avoir peur
vous pouvez dormir sur vos deux oreilles
et puis surtout faites de beaux rêves